[Música]
según el florido cuanto más desarrollada
está una economía más innovadora los
países necesitan innovación para
desarrollar sus economías especialmente
después del cob y especialmente en
países en vías de desarrollo pero nadie
sabe cómo traducir de forma eficaz la
innovación a nuestros contextos y es una
pregunta que ha estado rondando en mi
cabeza desde hace un tiempo y el reto
que asumí mi primera aproximación fue
acercarme a las nuevas tecnologías
tecnologías exponenciales y ver cómo las
traíamos a la región y efectivamente hay
que hacerlo es maravilloso pero si
hacemos únicamente eso no va a ser
suficiente siempre seremos seguidores y
la forma como se implementa esto en
países desarrollados es diferente a
veces en la forma como lo desarrollamos
en nuestros contextos por eso creo que
hay que cambiar la perspectiva hay que
complementar y hablando de perspectivas
mejor de esta historia donde un niño le
dice el papá papi papi ferrari es un
auto rojo que tiene un caballito verdad
sí hijo por qué porque creo que acabo de
ver uno nos acaba de pasar un auto rojo
con un caballo
y esto es lo que pasa hay que cambiar de
perspectiva y la realidad es que
hablando de innovación los héroes de
nuestra época son esas startups esos
tres jóvenes en un garaje que logran
acabar con los goliats de su industria
ellos son los davis de nuestra época y
para ellos tenemos incubadoras y
aceleradoras
premios capital
pero qué pasa con los julián es qué pasa
con los gobiernos con las empresas con
las grandes fundaciones para ellos
parece que la innovación está relegada
ellos no tienen un garaje para prosperar
y reinventarse y son importantísimos
porque emplean a millones de personas y
son fruto de prosperidad económica
de pronto tenemos que voltear la mirada
un poco más hacia esos socios o está
bits por hacia sus calidades porque el
problema es tan grave tema 15 que hace
una encuesta global muestra que el 94
por ciento de los heros se sienten
frustrados decepcionados o
desilusionados por el rendimiento de la
innovación en sus compañías y yo he
tenido la fortuna de trabajar con
compañías a través de la región
ayudándolos a que su innovación sí
funcione he encontrado que en muchos
casos el imaginario colectivo es que lo
que se necesita para innovar es esto
un saco cuello tortuga negro llamarse
steve y vivir en silicon valley
pareciera como si la innovación está
solamente en aquellas mentes brillantes
sino en todos los demás y eso no es
cierto para que la innovación funcione
se necesita una cosa
disciplina
así como en sus organizaciones tienen un
sistema de ventas un sistema legal o un
sistema financiero a la innovación hay
que tratarla igual tiene que ser un
sistema disciplinado y esto no para
coartar la creatividad sino para acabar
con el caos porque la realidad es que
todas las empresas todas las
organizaciones están tratando de ir de
punto a punto b donde punto a punto está
en el futuro y para eso el de legal
tiene una idea el de recursos humanos
tiene una idea de producción tiene una
idea
pero si eso no tiene estructura su
organización se ve más o menos así donde
lo que hace es que desperdicia capital
tiempo y dinero en un montón de ideas y
proyectos que al final no están
alineados ni a la estrategia ni nos
llevan dónde queremos llevar así que lo
primero que hay que hacer es tener un
sistema disciplinado de innovación lo
segundo es que imagínense que estamos en
una sala en un aeropuerto y sale la
azafata en un avión que pronto vamos a
tomar estos vuelos trasatlánticos y
salen azafata y dice lo sentimos el
piloto tuvo un contratiempo y no alcanza
a llegar algún voluntario que le
gustaría volar este avión se subiría a
usted en esa nave tenía riesgos de miedo
pero paradójicamente eso es lo que
hacemos con la innovación algún
voluntario que quiera entrar a esta
lluvia de ideas para ver cómo nos
alimentamos la empresa
eso no funciona en los demás sistemas en
el sistema legal tenemos abogados que se
han profesionalizado para eso en el
otros financieros en la innovación hay
que hacer lo mismo tenemos que
profesionalizar el rol del intra
emprendedor aquí el que nos va a ayudar
a llegar a ese punto ve en el futuro y
los sueños que sean esos intra
emprendedores los que nos ayuden a
reinventar los goliats de nuestra región
pero cómo hacerlo y buscando la solución
empecé a encontrarla en lugares
fortuitos lo primero fue en una calle en
américa latina' caminando me encontré
esta señal que decía pare de quejarse
o en un periódico donde ves esta ola fue
le dice ya sabes chili para la mayoría
de las personas va por el mundo dando
excusas y auto compadeciéndose supongo
que es más fácil quejarse acerca de la
vida que hacer algo por mejorarla esto
es una cuestión de actitud tenemos que
empezar a pensar en abundancia y no en
escasez tenemos que creernos que somos
capaces de generar grandes cambios
tenemos que creer en nosotros y en
nuestra gente porque sólo así vamos a
desbloquear su ingenio creativo
la innovación se trata sobre apuntar
lejos para luego acertar
y para eso tenemos una herramienta
increíble es una masa mojada frágil que
pesa unas tres libras del tamaño como de
una naranja cabe en la palma de la mano
representa el 2% de nuestro peso pero
consume el 20 por ciento de nuestras
calorías sanz cuál es el cerebro
tan importante que de viçosa dijo le
tengo una nueva dieta piense entre más
calorías entre más pensamos más calorías
quemamos y así es el cerebro es algo
maravilloso y les tengo una gran noticia
es igualito el que tenemos acá que
tienen en otras partes del mundo
funciona y juanito y es tan maravilloso
que robert frost poeta le escribió lo
siguiente decía el cerebro es algo
maravilloso comienza a funcionar en el
momento en que nos levantamos en la
mañana y no se detiene hasta que
llegamos al trabajo
si usted no quiere que le pase eso si
usted quiere que sus colaboradores y sus
intraemprendedores sigan innovando hay
que darles herramientas para pensar
diferente hay que darles herramientas
para pensar erróneamente miren esta
matriz en el eje x están los problemas o
los retos en el eje y las soluciones
estamos midiendo el nivel de certeza que
tanto conocemos un problema o una
solución y usualmente operamos en el
cuadrante superior derecho lo que
llamamos el pensamiento correcto
ahí es donde si usted llega a ser una
maestría le dicen acá vamos a estudiar
con casos de estudio que es un caso de
estudio usted conoce el problema conoce
la solución y como lo aplicaría en su
contexto ahí está toda la lógica de
aumentar ingresos disminuir gastos toda
la narrativa del roi todas las
herramientas como dov a espina de
pescado el paretón ahí tenemos la
premisa fundamental es que entre más
información tengamos mejores soluciones
tomamos mejores soluciones desarrollamos
pero qué pasa cuando no tenemos
suficiente información
que pasa cuando tenemos un problema que
conocemos pero no conocemos la solución
qué pasa con el parkinson ahí está el
problema pero no sabemos la solución qué
pasa con el alzheimer qué pasa con el
covite el año pasado yo veía un montón
de webinars de cómo adaptar tu empresa a
la pandemia pues no sé nunca había
habido una pandemia antes la última fue
hace 100 años
la realidad es que en ese caso no hay
información lo que tenemos son supuestos
y qué pasa cuando tenemos un problema en
donde conocemos la solución pero no
conocemos el problema me dicen o
danielle eso no pasa disipar ustedes
llegan un evento estos de tecnología y
no importa su problema inteligencia
artificial es la solución no importa su
problema vital la solución
parece casi que soluciones pasando
problemas la realidad es que en todos
los cuadrantes que no son el pensamiento
correcto lo que no tenemos es
información y no sabemos cómo navegar
supuestos y no sabemos cómo cuáles
herramientas a usar ahí es donde tenemos
que invitar a las personas a pensar
diferente a pensar erróneamente porque
en la realidad es que yo conozco más de
150 herramientas para navegar supuestos
y así como aprendemos el dof o la espina
de pescado deberíamos aprender estas las
realidades que acá tenemos que ir en
contra de esa narrativa tan corporativa
que nos dice no no no me traiga
problemas traigan soluciones man yo no
todo el tiempo las empresas están un
montón de tiempo y dinero en
solucionando el problema incorrecto
las personas que van a ser exitosas en
el siglo 21 no son aquellos quien saben
encontrar la solución sino aquellos que
aprenden a encontrar el problema
correcto y eso también tiene método
también en metodologías necesitamos
aprenderlas y apropiarnos déjenme les
digo por qué es tan importante encontrar
el problema correcto imagínense que
estamos en áfrica y está la planilla
africana mucho calor y dos jóvenes que
entran a la laguna a refrescarse y
cuando salen un león grande enorme muy
cerca dispuesto a atacarlos
lo primero que hacen es gritar y uno le
dice al otro rápido tenemos que huir y
el otro se siente empieza a ponerse los
zapatos
qué estás haciendo
y él le dice es que el problema no es
subir el problema es correr más rápido
que tú
se dan cuenta lo importante encontrar el
problema correcto
así que si tenemos creemos en nuestra
gente y nosotros mismos y tenemos las
soluciones y las herramientas para
adecuadas nos está faltando solamente un
componente
y visionarios necesitamos en nuestras
organizaciones y en nuestros países
líderes visionarios recuerden este 12 de
septiembre de 1962 cuando john f.kennedy
al frente de esta multitud dice en diez
años vamos a poner un hombre en la luna
no dijo cómo no dio un plan 20 una
visión que hubiera sido del famoso
discurso de martin luther king si se
hubiera parado en washington en ese día
caluroso cuando venía gente de todo el
país a oírlo y el diseño tengo un sueño
sueño que un día mis cuatro hijos
pequeños vivirán en una nación en donde
no serán juzgados por el color de su
piel sino por el contenido de su
carácter
más de nuctech y no dijo yo tengo un
plan en vez de un sueño y una visión y
luego con tristeza como todos los días
nos encontramos con líderes políticos
con planes de gobierno y líderes
empresariales con sus planes
estratégicos quien ofrece una visión
quien ofrece un sueño simon dine por un
temas de liderazgo decía no me gusta el
título de si yo creo que debemos
cambiarlo por silvio shift visión
officer alguien encargado de crear crear
y garantizar que la compañía esté en el
camino correcto para llegar a su visión
yo veo todas las empresas tienen escrito
una misión pero veo muy pocas que están
en una misión y eso es muy diferente y
bien lo importante y los resultados de
esto esta es una foto de bogotá en 1998
donde llega un grupo nuevo de líderes
políticos que tienen una visión que las
ciudades deberían ser para la gente y no
para los carros decían en ese momento
que ellos iban a trabajar no por los
periodistas que escribían los titulares
sino por los historiadores
dos años después esta misma calle se
veía así
si eres convicción dan resultados
diferentes y no hay nada más importante
que empezar a aplicar esto el momento es
ahora según la cepal la pandemia provoca
un aumento en los niveles de pobreza sin
precedentes en las últimas décadas e
impacta fuertemente la desigualdad y el
empleo de qué sirve traer innovación de
punta américa latina y empezar a pensar
diferente si eso no se va a ver
traducido en acabar con la desigualdad
en aumentar el empleo y reducir esa
pobreza vergonzosa
nuestra sociedad nos necesita y nos
necesita ahora y por eso estoy
promoviendo una alianza de las es la
esperanza que son esos jóvenes en un
garaje con la experiencia que son sus
cualidades porque juntos somos más si es
bloqueamos el talento y el ingenio
creativo de nuestra gente si les creemos
en ellos les damos las herramientas
correctas y tenemos líderes visionarios
y ponemos eso al servicio de los demás
sin duda así y sólo así estaremos a la
altura del momento histórico que nos
tocó vivir
muchas gracias
[Música]